Họng mới bẩy dự hút qua 2,5 năm năm 2018, tại khu bục trình lối thuộc mỏ khách thác đã của công ty chế giềm viếu hạn anh tốn,
sẽ cần đủ tình thành hoa đã sử ra vụ sật lời đáng hình trọc.
Tong tin bàn đầu, thưa điểm sử ra vụ việp.
Các ông, lo văn thời, sinh năm 2019,
lo văn khuy, sinh năm 2019, sinh năm 2019, sinh năm 2019, sinh năm 2019,
cùng chú tại tình ít bái khu, này là tình lạc ai.
Đăng ra đồng tại khu bục trình lối đã thị bất ngờ khu lượng lời nất đã từ trên lối sật lời xuống.
Họng qua, bong người từ vóng trên đường đi cấp kữ, 2 người mất tích,
đến tám sử 2,5 phút hôm nay, lực lượng cứu nạn kêu ổ công an tình thành hoa đã tình thấy khá hai thịt tệ nạn nhìn.
Hẹn các lực lượng chức năng đăng tích tục bảo vệ hệ chứ,
với hợp đu chạc làm gió mình như buồn sật lời.